sou paisagista
o estudo do projeto constrói acompanha a
paisagem há 22 anos
eu aprendi muito com isso além desse a
paisagista eu sou estrangeiros o francês
e começar com uma frase com uma citação
do nosso percurso que disse que eu havia
a descoberta não é olhar para novas
paisagens mas é criar um novo olhar e
espero poder trazer hoje para vocês um
novo olhar eu aprendi o ofício na frança
onde a natureza é totalmente domesticada
temos 0,03 por cento de que os sistemas
nativos e essas árvores que vem atrás de
mim som pelas do rei formadas parecer
com esses soldados
a dre estados pela mão do homem mas
nesses anos todos de profissão eu
aprendi a ecologia à ecologia hoje uma
palavra que a gente encontra até esta
manhã em pó
a gente até tem dúvidas sobre consentiu
da ecologia tecnologia é uma das
palavras de quem inventou essa palavra
eu estou das relações eu entre o que tem
três saber essa flor aqui
qual é a relação que existe a ideia hoje
de trazer justamente uma discussão
os cariocas chamado de dr vamos ter uma
dr
todo mundo junto entre o homem ea
natureza eu uso muito a ecologia da
paisagem na minha disciplina ea gente vê
que tudo tem uma relação com o outro do
indivíduo até biosfera todo ligado e um
pouco dessa visão que eu vou trazê lo
hoje aqui até porque essa questão de
relação com o ambiente tem várias
teorias das mais grotescas e se chama de
mickey mouse né onde a economia está à
frente de todo mundo
néné eu não lembro que mais alguém disse
isso duas pessoas acreditem em crescido
crescimento infinito
os economistas e os loucos
temos a procura da sustentabilidade
creio que todos as pessoas que estão
aqui juntos é trabalhar nesse sentido e
tal mas mais referente né não tem
economia se não tem sociedade não tem
sociedade não tem ambiente
então fazendo previsões e as isso
tipicamente gringo que adora números
vamos ver a reação no tempo se a vida
fosse em 24 horas
um exemplo é a vida na ceia a 4 milhões
600 mil anos
as quatro em dez da manhã como se fosse
uma crise em sonho aparece a vida no
fundo do mar na água mas desde 6
essas primeiras algas se associam com
outras e criou a fotossíntese oxigênio a
fotossíntese aparece através de uma
associação de uma colaboração entre
seres vivos
o tempo vá às plantas dinossauros e
mamíferos atuais e aí 47 minutos antes
- não segundos quando sete segundos
desculpa antes de meia noite aparece o
homo habilis aquele que segura uma
ferramenta com essa ferramenta
ele vai se afastar do na natureza
além disso essas ferramentas evoluíram
hoje temos ferramentas incríveis para
separar a gente da natureza uma tela de
computador ou smartphone a insuperável
aqui a pedra com aqui mas eu quero
chamar a atenção que a real diferença
está acima da linha do horizonte da
nossa cultura como sapiência aquele que
sabe mas será que sabemos tanto o
primeiro grande passo para se distanciar
na nossa querida natureza
estamos é proveniente dela é domesticar
mas a natureza
o trigo pois é continuamos comendo até
hoje e pegar umas coisas no nosso pior
inimigo o lobo e transformá-los e no seu
melhor amigo o cão mas além do tempo
uma relação sempre acontece no lugar um
cenário estamos todos a bordo desse não
sou linda do planeta no seu navio né
todos juntos o que fizemos no cenário
então como europeu pragmático quando
dizia chato eu fiz um pequeno exercício
resolvi pegar toda a superfície de terra
temos 30% de terra na superfície do
planeta o resto o efeito de águas
eu resolvi dividir a quantia de pessoas
que têm no planeta na época da crise
dizendo da domesticação da natureza
tínhamos todos uma bela fazenda quase 10
milhões de metros quadrados por pessoa
o teto municipal está no centro dessa
imagem a gente vê aqui a baía de
guanabara com as moças muito esquisitas
na superfície da água
e aqui chegamos diretamente pegar num
historial 18 minutos em 2012 sete
bilhões de habitantes em um mundo em um
jardim
eu tenho um quadrado de 145 metros cada
um teatro municipal um picasso de rua
nos edifícios mundo virou pequeno um dos
mudamos o tamanho do mundo pegando os
números 3% desse mundo é feito de cidade
desde por cento de cultivo 30% de pasto
e o resto vai sendo fragmentado com uma
série de equipamentos e infra-estruturas
entre elas mas somos tão diferente assim
da natureza pra gente pegar tanto a
distância tanto a cerimônia com ela
acho que não olhando para os fatos para
a biologia é paciência
a gente vê que temos em comum muita
coisa com espécies próximas
eu nunca mais tomei vinho da mesma
maneira depois de descobrir isso e tem
um fato assim que daria um segundo teste
maravilhoso somos um ecossistema
não sei se vocês sabem mas temos dentro
da gente sem me bilhões de seres vivos
temos mais sérias vivos dentro da gente
que tem estrela nossa galáxia
então somos a natureza desta dentro a
gente volta da gente
onde está esse limite nos seus sonhos
fui muito bem abordado mais cedo com
cidade sonhamos há alguns anos atrás e
aí me veio a abertura de um seriado que
os pais viam esse ser é do paço em 6884
dallas alguns conhecem você pode chegou
a passar aqui olha a imagem da abertura
do desse seriado estádio
o agronegócio é uma zona industrial uma
cidade feita de concreto de prédios
revestidos de óculos ray-ban uma fazenda
mais artérias de carro individual mais
difícil é bão agronegócio petróleo
dallas texas e cultura é essa que
fabrica nossa cidade
se alguém próximo de vocês alguém que os
elegeu o que você quer eleger um técnico
que cuida da sociedade o profissional
que desenha elas irá apresentar isso pra
vocês dizendo que isso é ordem e
progresso
gente não é isso aí ferro e fogo e
deixarmos nesse jardim uma um rastro
longe dos olhos e se chama se delimite
invisível minha maneira de viver cria
essa forma no planeta esses degraus
esculpidos na pedra para extrair ferro
minérios e se a fama que mudar nosso
planeta queremos chatear ele cortar ele
aliás a francesa em quadradinhos sem
olhar o que tem aqui antes tem uma
natureza antes da gente e ela tem 4,6
bilhões
ela tem um dia inteiro de vida e temos
sul 47 segundos para aparecer nela eu
acho que seguimos padrões culturais um
pouco perdidos estamos seguindo um rumo
que provavelmente não levará no bom
sentido
eu quero chamar atenção em relação uma
maneira que a gente produz não só nossa
cidade mas nos seus objetos de maneira
linear
se extrai um bem se transforma ele se
usa ele e se descarta ele esse é um
sistema que criar morte nessa imagem
o passado está vivo ele está se
decompondo bactérias estão transformando
ele enterra ele voltará a ser vegetal e
voltassem animal esse passado está vivo
que está mortos inspiração de plástico
essa espécie de machico não demoram 500
anos para se degradar de mão 500 nos
passeios fazê-la plástico virá menor mas
ele continua sempre plástico
não podemos mais fazer as coisas de
maneira nem há necessidade nem os seus
bens
olhando para o mapa tirando a idéia do
quadrado já aplicando no mapa e se um
pouco o lugar no jardim nosso jardim a
todos onde está vermelho está totalmente
alterado as técnicas naturais onde está
verde intenção de gastar quase alterado
diretamente não prometi quimicamente
pelo a e vem num momento que é a
natureza discutir com a gente e será que
precisamos esperar esse tempo da
natureza discutir com gente
eu até um frio na barriga no león etapa
no rio de janeiro
temos fragilidade mental
temos chuva é silva com a casa você vê
no jornal escrito a chuva mata a chuva
alaga a chuva será o que é mentira
a chuva traz vida o que mata o que alaga
ea cidade mal feita
não é a chuva
e eu chamasse a atenção para essa foto
aqui eu não desejo esse evento a ninguém
nem no pior inimigo
mas reparem neste momento voltarmos a
ser um neste momento agimos como uma
espécie
trabalhamos em prol da espécie e não em
prol do indivíduo
precisamos esperar que a natureza deu
uma bronca na gente
não podemos nos sabemos o suficiente não
somos homo sapiens se vai ter que chegar
nesse ponto para voltar a ser humano
para entender que somos a natureza
mudamos nossos sonhos
hoje temos as imagens do avatar a
natureza como referência queremos outro
mundo depois do rio a escola humberto
viana o fritz lang metrópolis
agora temos o avatar james cameron
a natureza faz coisas incríveis você
pegar um óvulo um sistema que o soe
difunde um outro serra um mais um é cada
um
a natureza consegue fazer isso ele pegou
essa mesma célula e dividir ela inúmeras
células e faz de um mais do que um
a natureza é uma fonte inesgotável de
referências e eu gostaria de mostrar a
vocês um mapa do ouro
quanto mais vermelho mais biodiversidade
o rio de janeiro está sentada num pote
de ouro e natureza podemos aprender
muito organização de uma maneira bonita
com o vôo de andorinhas podemos aprender
a vencer a escuridão da ignorância como
um vagalume em iluminar a escuridão com
seu próprio corpo com sua própria
biologia
podemos construir cidades assim na
cidade que produzem a água cidade que
purifica a água se deve que seqüestram
carbono cidade que sejam habitats para
outra espécie a não ser a nossa eu quero
fazer uma cidade e assim vamos parar com
esse mito do mais forte vence
existe um pouquinho natureza mais
rendimento existe muito mais um
mutualista trabalhar juntos trabalhar
com os outros estava com natureza tal
esse pássaro que limpa os dentes do
código
olha isso aqui esse é um instrumento
formidável e sistema que vivem junto com
as raízes
tal como temos milhões de ser da gente
os árvores têm sedes que vivem junto com
as raízes
eu vejo estradas aqui como via cidade do
brejo ante esses filamentos brancos
transferem carbono do mais forte ou mais
fraco aquele que tem menos acesso à luz
esse fundo regulamento pega o maior e da
menor
esse é um bom exemplo do que a natureza
faz pra gente sabe o que esse país é
campeão mundial de biodiversidade o seu
brasão uma estrela
isso aqui é muito mais importante do que
11 os 22 homens segundo atrás de uma
bola com os cortes de cabelo meio
esquisito esse é o mapa da
biodiversidade temos aqui matas pluviais
temos aqui com esse sistema seco cerrado
caatinga se dividem nos seis biomas 700
considera um manguezal com um biombo mas
o submarino e do outro lado temos a
nossa cidade enquanto mais marrom mais
gente por metro quadrado temos a
densidade e aqui está nosso ecossistema
de relações
será que nossas estradas proponho o
mesmo serviço que as ferramentas branco
costura natureza trabalham com a
natureza favorecem ela trabalha em
conjunto e mutualismo deixou a pergunta
para os profissionais então vamos mudar
tudo
eu tinha um mundo velho eu tenho um
mundo novo
vocês vão escolher qual mundo o velho
novo
obrigada eu também e vamos mudar um
pouco essa idéia que o nosso pra cima ou
para baixo
vamos rever tudo estamos no século 21
a cidade tem que ser o organismo também
a cidade tem que ser a vida a cidade tem
que ser ela tem que prestar no mínimo os
mesmos serviços que os sistemas que eram
antes estavam então vamos olhar por
exemplo uma árvore
emprestar centenas de serviços
ecossistêmicos
a cidade faz isso tudo aí eu chamo meus
colegas arquitetos urbanistas
engenheiros paisagistas
vamos fazer um pouco mais do que sobre
pó que lá relógio
vou fazer mais por natureza vou fazer
mais com a natureza
eu acho que tá aí o desafio um saudável
o desafio de ser o mais forte o mais
inteligente prestar o máximo possível de
serviços ecossistêmicos né está aqui
semana visa chuva chuva aqui no mata
chuva aqui da vida é a cidade se
urbanista não propõe um plano desse a
sua proposta está propondo aquele
sistema linear que não tem vida
urbanista hoje tem que provar a vida na
cidade e temos pouca água a água eo vê a
gente vai fechar com isso depois em
breve
são tudo bola grande
toda a água que tem no planeta é salgada
e doce bola média toda a água doce estão
vendo uma bola menorzinho azul e se há
água potável alcançável pela mão do
homem
a maior parte da água potável está
debaixo do solo e custará o preço do
petróleo a partir de lope nosso próprio
corpo efeito de 70% de água
a gente ama muito água a gente nem sabe
a pessoa que você ama e feita de 70% de
água você ama muito água e nem sabe
disso então vamos sonhar um pouco com
uma cidade que se darão uma máquina de
vida que prioriza o abastecimento de na
alimentação onde a água diário esse
gênio né
tudo tudo fundamental a gente não ficar
em pé se esse gênio sem água
assim calorias alimentos também né
para fechar aqui com a imagem do rio de
janeiro rio de janeiro nem tem três
palavras rio de janeiro uma das suas
palavras sobre a água já né
isso aqui lagoa praia de botafogo hoje
você passa por lá você passa a pensar de
carro mas um pesadelo pegar
engarrafamento era um brejo uma série de
rios descendo do maciço e debaixo dessa
cidade
temos uma série de rios que a gente nem
sabe que existe em que ficam longe dos
olhos até o rio carioca que dá o nome ao
cidadão do rio a quem sabe onde está o
rio carioca
ele está debaixo desse idec aí escondido
ele passa uma estação de tratamento de
esgoto como que um rio passa numa
estação de tratamento de esgoto como
alguém podia admitir a tratar um rio
como esgoto
pra mim é um sinal de fracasso você não
foi esgotada e usa um rio com o esgoto
não pode não pode tem que ter e esgoto
direito e por que a gente é um sonho uma
cidade chamada rio de janeiro que o rio
que dá o nome à cidade apareça seja
alcançável e volte a ser o habitar de
muitas outras espécies
então vamos voltar pra casa com duas
cores verde azul um fácil está na
bandeira
difícil é que ela mata atlântica só
temos sete por cento dela
imagina e vivência 7% do seu apartamento
esse incômodo e aí pra fechar eu
gostaria de pegar o duas palavras que
atuam na bandeira do brasil ordem e
progresso e completar ela com a palavra
inteira é uma citação do vice do conto e
tem três palavras e eu acho que faz
muita falta nessa história de relação
um amor como base a ordem como princípio
e o progresso como fim
obrigado